hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and what if i told
you that the original joyboy knew that
he was going to lose the war 800 years
ago and that he knew that he was going
to die but he also knew that he would
one day return and so he set a secret
master plan into motion a plan that
involved his own death and revival a
plan that involved zunesha the nefertari
royal family and the ancient weapons and
a plan that if uncovered will finally
reveal the true meaning behind the straw
hat the d-clan and more this plan has
been over 800 years in the making and
all those crazy twists and turns about
luffy's devil fruit were just one part
of this master plan so let's get into it
you guys know the drill if you enjoy our
one piece content and you want to
encourage us to keep going just leave a
quick like and comment it only takes a
second but it really helps with that
youtube algorithm and of course
subscribing to the channel is a
completely free but very important way
of directly supporting us finally this
video will contain one piece manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned okay so i recently
made a video about the void century and
in that video i argued that the void
century in one piece was inspired by the
punic wars with the world government
representing rome the ancient kingdom
representing carthage and joy boy
representing the brilliant general
hannibal i'll leave the link to that
video down in the description if you
want to check it out but while i was
working on that video one part of
joyboy's story really stood out to me i
realized that he must have known ahead
of time that he would lose the war
against the alliance that would
eventually become the world government
and he must have known that he was going
to die however he also knew that he
would one day return through the nika
devil fruit and so he initiated a secret
master plan which set the stage for his
eventual revival 800 years later our
first hint that joyboy was planning
something big in the future were of
course the ponoglyphs which were left
behind by the ancient kingdom in order
to instruct future generations about
several things that will be critical for
eventually defeating the world
government this includes information
about the three ancient weapons
information about joyboy's eventual
return directions for locating laugh
tale and so on we know that the kozuki
clan created the podoglyphs and we can
assume that this was done on the direct
orders of boy after all the
ryugyupatoglyph is a personal message
from joyboy to poseidon and the
inhabitants of fishman island this
suggests that joyboy had a personal and
direct control over the creation of the
poneglyphs they weren't created by just
some random person or organization
joyboy was behind it all and in fact it
is believed that joyboy's apology to
poseidon actually predates the creation
of the ponoglyphs by about a hundred
years this could mean that the original
joyboy was already dead by the time the
ponoglyphs were created but joyboy
clearly made preparations for what will
happen after he dies he likely knew
ahead of time that he would lose the war
800 years ago and that he would be
killed but he instructed the kozuki clan
to create the ponoglyphs after his death
in order to set the stage for his
eventual return because he knew that
someday someone would come along and
finally fulfill that promise he made to
fishman island as i argued in my void
sentry video i believe that joyboy was a
brilliant commander and tactician just
like hannibal of carthage and i believe
that he led the ancient kingdom in a war
against the alliance of kingdoms that
would eventually become the world
government he ultimately lost the war
and the world government tried their
best to erase joy boy and the ancient
kingdom from history and this gave birth
to what we know today as the void
century but because the original joy boy
knew that someone would one day succeed
him as the next joy boy through the
awakening of the nika devil fruit he
initiated a secret master plan 800 years
in the making and the podoglyphs were
just the beginning the fact that joyboy
would return in some capacity is
referenced multiple times in the story
from the seeking prophecy about the two
sovereigns to that message from joyboy
that the roger pirates found on
laughtale in chapter 963
we learned that the minx and the kozuki
clan made a pact hundreds of years ago a
pact that committed them to defending
each other in times of need i believe
that this pact was made on joyboy's
direct orders and that it was just one
component of the master plan that he
initiated before his death next we need
to talk about the nefertari family a
royal family that has always been an
outlier they were one of the 20 royal
families who established the world
government but they were the only royal
family that decided not to move to
marijuana instead they chose to remain
in alabasta while still technically
joining the world government but by
refusing to live as celestial dragons in
marijua the nefertari undermined the
very concept of celestial dragons if
these celestial dragons really were such
superior godly beings who lived in a
holy land that was so much better than
anywhere else in the world then why
would the nefertari willingly reject
this type of life the decision that the
nefertari made makes the entire
celestial dragon system look bad and it
clearly undermines their most important
messaging the revery arc confirmed that
the nefertari are seen as traitors by
the celestial dragons and yet the
nefertari don't seem to have been
punished for their betrayal that is
something that's always kind of bothered
me since we know just how ruthless and
cruel the celestial dragons can be i
mean they're willing to destroy an
entire kingdom if one celestial dragon
is hurt and yet they're not prepared to
take any punitive action against the
nefertari i believe that the reason why
the nefertari have never been attacked
by the celestial dragons is the fact
that pluton is said to be somewhere in
alabasta the celestial dragons must
believe that the nefertari either have
or could potentially gain access to
pluton and they're not willing to risk
fighting the nefertari because they
don't want to risk facing pluton in
battle on top of this we know that the
nefertari have apparently been hiding
upon a glyph from the world government
which from everything we know
constitutes an extremely grave offense
so why would the nefertari do this why
would they risk so much if they truly
believed in the world government system
then why would they refuse to join the
other royal families in marijuana and
why would they hide one of the most
dangerous objects for the world
government upon a glyph from their
fellow founding families
as i mentioned in my video on the void
century i believe that the nefertari are
not what they appear to be i think that
they may actually be plants or spies
sent by joyboy to infiltrate the world
government i think that once joyboy
realized that he couldn't win the war he
instructed the nefertari to switch sides
and become one of the 20 families that
established the world government but
their real mission was not to help the
world government but to use their status
as one of the founding families to set
the stage for joyboy's return this
mission included hiding poneglyphs from
the world government protecting pluton
from the world government until the time
was right to activate it and who knows
what else now of course if the nefertari
had agreed to become celestial dragons
they would not have been able to do any
of this a different royal family would
have been in charge of alabasta and
there is no guarantee that this other
family would have carried out joy boy's
will they might have betrayed the
location of the podoglyph and pluton to
the world government so the nefertari
had to remain in alabasta and they had
to pretend to support the world
government while secretly preparing for
joy boy's return this secret mission
that the nefertari family had taken upon
themselves may have been forgotten over
the many centuries and as such it is
possible that king cobra and vivi don't
even know the truth at the moment but i
believe that they will be made aware of
it when the time is right or rather vivi
will because king cobra may already be
dead after the reverie that being said i
do believe that vv will eventually learn
the truth about joyboy's plan and the
ancient weapon pluton and all of this
will play an important role in the final
showdown of the series
so here's what we know about joyboy's
master plan so far in order to set the
stage for his eventual return the kozuki
clan created the ponoglyphs and made a
pact with the minks the nefertari family
infiltrated the world government from
within and the joy boy's eventual return
was foretold both on the ryugyu
ponoglyph and on laughtale there are
still several other components to
joyboy's plan including the d-clan the
straw hat and even the famous c-shanty
binks sake and yeah i know that some of
you might think i'm crazy for claiming
that an innocent pirate song like bing
sake is part of some secret master plan
so let's address that first pink sake is
a famous sea shanty that has been sung
by pirates for centuries and in fact i
am proposing that it has been around
ever since the void century being sake
is not just a song it is actually an
oral history which tells the tragic
story of the void century the dawn of
the world and laugh tale i mean the
final line of the song actually contains
the term varayi banashi which can be
literally translated as laugh tale never
ending never wandering our funny
traveling tale are laugh tale the entire
song is full of potentially important
clues going to deliver being sake by
sailing to the ends of the sea i.e to
the final island if you lose your nerve
this breath could be your last but if
you just hold on the morning sun will
rise the dawn of the world the sun god
nika i mean you get the point a lot can
be read into these lyrics and with good
reason what better way to preserve an
important message for future generations
in a world where the truth has been
banned and erased from history than to
preserve it as something like a song or
poem something that never needs to be
written down and yet can be passed on
from generation to generation a funny
tale that keeps traveling from one
generation to the next in fact i have
some personal experience with this kind
of thing i am serbian and epic poems
that were passed down orally from
generation to generation played an
important role in our history the
serbian people lived under occupation by
the ottoman empire for centuries and any
books or other written records that
celebrated serbian heroes who fought
against the ottomans would have been
prohibited on top of that most people
were illiterate anyway so even if
written records did exist no one would
have been able to read them so the
serbian people passed on their history
in the form of epic poems which told the
stories of medieval serbian heroes who
fought against the ottomans and also
stories of the haiduk's serbian outlaws
who waged the guerrilla-style war
against the ottoman occupiers for
centuries these epic poems were passed
on from generation to generation orally
so each new poet had to memorize the
entire poem in order to share it with
others it was only in the 1800s that
these poems were actually written down
and published as part of various
collections so yeah if joyboy wanted to
send a secret message to future
generations a message which gave them
hints about laugh tale and the dawn of
the world pink's sake would have been
the perfect method in fact the lyrics of
being sake may turn out to be even more
important than we thought because they
could be a part of a cipher that will
eventually be used to unlock an
important secret such as the location of
the ancient weapons or something along
those lines and this brings me to the
true meaning of the straw hat including
that mysterious giant straw hat in
marijua
there are several loose threads that we
need to pick up and bring together in
order to discover the real meaning
behind the straw hat first up we have
the lyrics of being sake once again one
thing that caught my eye early on was
the fact that the viz and funimation
versions of the translation include the
phrase bid farewell to weaver's town as
in a town where something is being
weaved in other versions this is
translated as hometown but both versions
work for what i am about to say next if
we go back to chapter 272
we see that on the ruins of shandora
there is a text written in the same
ancient script that was used on the
poneglyphs these are the words that
robin reads there hold the truth in your
heart keep your mouth silent we are the
ones who weave history with the
reverberations of the great bell this
short text implies that a secret is
preserved in your heart but kept hidden
from the outside world it also implies
that this secret is deeply tied to
history to important historical events
and whoever wrote the text clearly
intends to influence history to weave
history in some way finally there's
toki's prophecy from chapter 919
right before she apparently died toki
proclaimed like the moon you are
ignorant of the dawn if there is one
ardent wish that must be fulfilled it
will be when nine shadows are cast woven
together through 20 years of moonlit
nights only then shall you understand
the radiance of dawn these different
bits of information may not seem
connected at first and they are hundreds
of chapters apart in the manga but they
do have a common thread and yes pun
intended because i'm talking about the
reference to weaving bidding farewell to
weaver's town we are the ones who weave
history shadows woven together through
20 years and how is a straw hat created
in the first place
through the process of weaving the
weaver's town or hometown in bing sake
is the ancient kingdom bing sake which
they are delivering is the secret
history that joy boy and his followers
are protecting and it is also the ideal
of freedom that they want to bring out
of the void century and into the present
time the void century is a part of
history that was erased by the world
government a part of history that was
ripped from the fabric of time but
joyboy and his followers are keeping the
threads alive so that one day this
important piece of history that was
ripped out can be woven back together
again and once it is woven back together
once the truth comes out the world
government will fall because the message
of freedom and equality that the ancient
kingdom represents is too powerful for
the tyranny of the world government to
overcome that is exactly why they went
through all that trouble to erase it
from history because they know how
dangerous to their very existence this
idea is the straw hat is woven together
from straw just like the dawn of the
world will one day be woven together
from all the secret and seemingly loose
threads that joyboy and the ancient
kingdom left behind the straw hat is the
most simple and most visible enduring
symbol of the dawn of the world and its
passing from generation to generation
mirrors the passing of bink's sake from
generation to generation it also mirrors
the passing of the information hidden on
the pondoglyphs from generation to
generation and so on the world
government loathes the straw hat because
it symbolizes everything they fear the
most and everything that they try to
erase from history on the surface the
straw hat may seem like a completely
innocent and innocuous accessory but for
those who know and are trying to hide
the truth about the void century the
straw hat is nothing less than a
declaration of war and all of this talk
about weaving threads of fate brings me
to another important topic the fates in
greek mythology we already know that oda
takes a lot of inspiration from greek
mythology after all all three ancient
weapons are based on deities from greek
mythology and yes this includes pluton
pluton is often associated with roman
mythology but the romans got the word
and the deity from the greeks now in
greek mythology the fates are three
women who determine the destiny of
everything and everyone and on many
occasions they are said to have even
greater power than the gods they spend
their entire days spinning the threads
of fate their thread is the line of life
itself and once a thread is snipped off
the person whose lifeline that was dies
clotho is the woman who spins a new
thread when a new baby is born la cases
determines the length of each thread and
atropos chooses the cause of death for
each person and she then snips the
thread when that person's life is
supposed to end since they are the ones
who decide destiny the ones who weave
destiny the fates know what will happen
in the future and all oracles and
prophecies are just tiny glimpses into
what the fates know i think that this
concept of the fates will become more
important in one piece as the story
continues and all of those prophecies
about the dawn of the world and the
concept of the will of thee will one day
be woven together like the threads of
fate or the threads of a straw hat we
may even see the three fates from greek
mythology being associated with the
three ancient weapons uranus could be
the nika devil fruit which has been
reincarnated inside a new person a new
thread poseidon controls powerful living
creatures the seekings which symbolizes
life and the threat of life itself and
of course pluton is a battleship which
can destroy life and so it snips the
threads of many now let's circle back to
the straw hat and especially that giant
straw hat that is being held inside a
freezing vault-like room in marijuana
this i admit is a real mystery and many
have suggested that this could be the
straw hat that belonged to the original
joy boy however if the world government
is trying to completely erase joy boy
the ancient kingdom and their symbols
from history then why would they not
destroy the straw hat
why keep it in this strange room as if
trying to preserve it when you could
just destroy it and then no one would
ever find it while i believe that the
straw hat in general is a symbol of joy
boy's master plan and therefore of joy
boy's will could this specific hat have
some sort of special ability which makes
it impossible to destroy and is the cold
temperature required in order to keep
this hat's special power from activating
potentially but the hat could also be
one of the keys to deciphering the truth
about joyboy's master plan maybe imusama
is keeping it on ice because it actually
contains some important information like
maybe something is written on it or
engraved inside of it and maybe the cold
is somehow preventing the letters from
fading or something i don't know i'm not
a scientist perhaps imusama knows that
there's a secret message on the straw
hat but he or she is unable to decipher
it at this point for some reason but
this message might be too important to
destroy and so the hat has been
preserved it's hard to say what's really
going on with this straw hat based on
the limited information that we have so
far but there has to be some good reason
why this hat has been carefully
preserved rather than just destroyed
along with everything else related to
the ancient kingdom i could totally see
robin finally solving the mystery of the
giant straw hat during the climax of the
story but we'll have to wait and see
definitely let me know what you think of
the giant straw hat at marijuana what is
its significance and why hasn't it been
destroyed why is it being kept in this
frozen vault almost like imusama is
deliberately trying to preserve it let
me know down below finally we need to
talk about the d clan because along with
the ponoglyphs the nefertari family bing
sake and the straw hat i believe that
the d-clan is also an important aspect
of joy boy's master plan
there are a ton of theories out there on
what the d-clan is and what the d stands
for in a previous video i argued that
perhaps only members of the d-clan are
able to awaken the nika devil fruit and
because the d-clan members are so rare
no one was able to awaken the fruit
until luffy but even if that were the
case it still wouldn't explain where the
d-clan actually came from what makes
them so special some have suggested that
members of the d-clan are all
descendants of the original joy boy
meaning that they are all related by
blood but because it's been 800 years
since the death of joy boy they are very
distant relatives and over the centuries
many of them forgot what the d in their
name even means this theory would have
to account for the fact that giants like
jaguar d saul and his family are also
members of the d-clan but if we assume
that giants and humans can't have
children with each other then this
theory could technically be possible
another popular theory is that the
d-clan are descendants of the original
joy boys crew so they're not all related
by blood but they do all trace their
origins to the void century and to
joyboy himself i think that this second
scenario is more likely i believe that
joyboy created the d-clan himself in
order to advance his master plan a plan
that would only come to fruition
centuries after his death members of the
d clan may be descendants of joy boy's
crew or they may be the descendants of a
secret society that joyboy established a
secret society dedicated to advancing
his master plan and his will after his
death either way it's clear to me that
members of the d-clan have an important
role to play in the coming final
showdown against the world government
and they will almost certainly turn out
to be instrumental in ushering in the
dawn of the world now several big
questions remain do the members of the
d-clan have any sort of special powers
or abilities compared to normal people
are they more likely to embrace the will
of joy boy than normal people and if so
why and what does the d stand for anyway
the d could stand for destiny because
they are destined to fulfill joyboy's
plan or for devil in the sense that
devils are the enemies of gods and the
d-clan are the natural enemies of the
celestial dragons but i think that the d
very likely stands for dawn because that
word dawn is everywhere in one piece and
it has been foreshadowed from the very
beginning romance dawn is the name of
the very first chapter the dawn of the
world is the epic world changing event
that the kozuki and the minks have been
waiting for for centuries toki's
prophecy places a strong emphasis on the
coming dawn and so on members of the
d-clan may have a special will that has
somehow been inherited by each and every
one of them the will of joyboy which
will one day fulfill joyboy's master
plan and bring about the dawn of the
world but if that is the case we would
need some sort of explanation for how
this will is inherited in the first
place we know that devil fruits seem to
have a will of their own but it appears
that not all members of the d-clan have
been devil fruit users
goldie roger was not a devil fruit user
as kaido confirmed in chapter 1047
and this means that roger could not have
inherited any sort of will from a devil
fruit so if the connection isn't devil
fruits what is the explanation do
members of the d-clan just have some
sort of special destiny are they all
chosen ones who are favored by the gods
or the universe or something or are they
just normal people who happen to find
themselves in extraordinary situations
because that de-initial in their names
leads others to treat them differently
which makes it all a sort of
self-fulfilling prophecy i think it's
probably a little bit of both
members of the d-clan do have a special
role to play in the one-piece story
which means that fate is definitely a
factor here but i would like to argue
that it's not just about fate throughout
the course of this video i've been
suggesting that the original joyboy
predicted his own defeat and death and
that he carefully constructed a master
plan that has been 800 years in the
making this plan involved the kozuki
clan and the ponoglyphs the alliance
between the kozuki and the minx in
anticipation of the dawn of the world
the nefertari family's refusal to live
in marijua the treasure left behind on
laughtale the true meaning of being sake
and the powerful symbolism of the straw
hat the existence of the d clan is
likely another aspect of joyboy's plan
it wasn't fate that formed the d-clan in
the first place it was joyboy himself
we don't know what exactly makes the
d-clan special we don't know whether
they possess a special power or a
special destiny but i believe that their
origins can be traced directly back to
joy boy and the secret master plan that
he set into motion over 800 years ago
maybe the d-clan are descendants of
joyboy's crew or maybe they're the
descendants of a secret society that was
formed after the fall of the ancient
kingdom in order to keep joyboy's ideals
alive in secret
whatever their true origins are i don't
think that their existence will turn out
to be a coincidence or an act of fate
they are not individuals who were chosen
by gods or by the universe instead they
were deliberately chosen by joy boy as
part of a wide-ranging master plan for
finally defeating the world government
and ushering in the dawn of the world we
still don't know all the specific
details of this master plan we only have
a rough outline that includes many loose
threads
but these threads will be woven together
eventually just like the threads in a
straw hat in order to reveal the epic
climax of the entire one piece story
if you guys enjoyed this video and you
want to see more in the future leave a
quick like and comment it only takes a
second but it helps me with that youtube
algorithm and remember that subscribing
and hitting that notification bell is a
completely free but very real way of
directly supporting the channel don't
forget to let me know what you think the
d clan is down in the comments below i
really want to hear your takes finally
if you're looking for a video to watch
next check out my video on the void
century link in the description as
always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys